Growing up in a Christian home, I heard many sermons about Jesus being God.
I believed it and it always made sense to me.
But for some reason, I thought the evidence for it was just a few isolated passages,
maybe in the Gospel of John and a few in the letters of Paul.
As I got older and really started to own my own faith and study the Scriptures more
closely, I began to realize that the idea that Jesus is God is central to the entire
biblical narrative.
Years ago, I had a conversation with a friend of mine.
It was late one night in college and we were up talking about God and the afterlife
and religion. And he said something that for some reason at that point in my life
stuck with me. He said, you know, of all the great world religious leaders,
Jesus is the only one who claimed to be God in human flesh.
As I thought about it, I realized that he's right.
Other religious figures claimed to tell us how to get to God.
or how to find truth, but Jesus claimed to be God.
And he gave powerful evidence, fulfilled prophecy and miracles to back up that
claim.
Jesus said the most important question we can answer in life is related to his own
identity. In Mark 8:29, Jesus asked, Who do you say that I am?
Muhammad certainly didn't claim to be God.
He claimed to be a prophet who revealed the will of Allah.
And Buddha didn't claim to be God either.
Buddha claimed to reveal the path to enlightenment.
But Jesus, on the other hand, claimed to be divine.
He claimed to be God in human flesh.
The Old Testament prepares the way for the coming of Jesus.
Luke 24:27 says,
in all the scriptures, the things concerning himself.
Let me highlight just briefly the things that Jesus said and did to reveal
that he is God.
First, Jesus has the authority to forgive sins that were committed against God
himself. In Mark chapter 2, a group of men bring a paralytic to Jesus
and Jesus announces by his own authority that the man's sins are forgiven.
Because the religious leaders believed that only God could forgive sins committed
against him, they accused Jesus of blasphemy but rather than backing down, Jesus
healed the paralytic demonstrating that he spoke with the authority of
God. Second, Jesus allowed people to worship him, which was something only
God was supposed to receive. After Jesus walked on water he got in the boat and
Matthew 14:33 says that the disciples worshipped him saying truly you
are the Son of God. If Jesus were not truly God he would have stopped the disciples
and other people from worshiping him.
In fact this is what we see happen in Scripture.
In Acts 14 it describes how Paul and Barnabas are in Lystra and they perform a
miracle and the people fall down to worship them but they stop and they say no
don't worship us only worship God we see the same thing happen again in Revelation
19. John falls down to worship the angel and again the angel says
do not worship me stop worship God alone and yet Jesus allowed
people to worship him why because he understood himself as God in human
flesh. Third, Jesus claimed the name of God.
In John chapter 8 the religious leaders are critiquing Jesus because he claimed to
have been around during the time of Abraham.
They're saying wait a minute Abraham lived a couple thousand years ago and you're
not even 50 how can this be? Well in reminiscence of Exodus chapter 3 verse
14 when God first appears and reveals himself to Moses.
And Moses asks who he is. He says, I am who I am.
Jesus turns and looks at the religious leaders and in John 8:58 he says,
truly truly I say to you before Abraham was I am.
And they pick up stones to kill him because by claiming this name Jesus was making
himself out to be equal to God. Fourth, other people including
inspired biblical writers referred to Jesus as God.
Hebrews 1:8 says, but of the Son he says your throne O God
is forever and ever. The author of Hebrews understood Jesus as the eternal
God who reigns forever.
And in Titus 2:13, the Apostle Paul, who had seen the risen Jesus,
says the appearing of the glory of our great God and Savior, Jesus Christ.
The Apostle Paul understood Jesus to be both God and Savior.
We've only considered a handful of examples, but the consistent narrative from the
preparation in the Old Testament through the entirety of the New Testament is
that Jesus was and is divine.
Personally speaking, understanding that Jesus was and is God was a
game changer. I began to realize this isn't just a secondary theological issue in
the scriptures, but the heart of the scriptures is that God has revealed himself in
Jesus Christ. And this needs to affect the way I live my life, how I spend my money,
my time, use my body, my profession, everything should be geared towards following
and submitting to and loving Jesus who is the Lord of the universe.
So here's the question for you. Have you made a decision to be a follower of Jesus?
I grew up in a Christian home and I heard the gospel a lot.
Sometimes it was just words until I hit that point in my life where I realized that
I too was a sinner and needed Jesus.
Because the gospel basically says that God has created us in his image.
He has a plan for our lives, but all of us have done certain wrong things and they
separate us from a holy God. And the only way we can have salvation is if
we put our faith and trust in Jesus Christ, God in human flesh who died
on the cross for our sins and paid the price that we deserved so are
you willing to turn from your sins and repent and trust and follow jesus
if you do the bible says people in heaven rejoice and that you personally will
have eternal life